Divide.
Simplify the answer and write
as a mixed number.
So we have 4 divided by 2/3, and
we've seen when you divide
by the fraction, it's the same
thing as multiplying by its
reciprocal.
So this is going to be the
same thing as 4 times the
reciprocal of 2/3, which is 3/2,
just swapping the bottom
and the top number, the
denominator and the numerator.
Now, 4, we've seen this before,
where we're saying,
OK, well, we know how to
multiply fractions.
You multiply the numerators
times each other and the
denominators times
each other, but 4
doesn't look like a fraction.
Well, you always have to
remember: a whole number can
be written as that same
whole number over one.
4 is the same thing as 4/1.
And now this becomes kind of
a plain vanilla multiplying
fractions problem.
And so we can just
multiply it out.
We could just say this is 4
times 3, which would be 12
over 1 times 2, which
would be 2.
Or we could divide right now.
Well, let's do it both
ways, actually.
So we could say this is 4 times
3 in the numerator,
which is 12, over 1 times 2 in
the denominator, which is 2.
Now, what is 12 divided by 2?
12/2 is the same thing
as 12 divided by 2.
Well, this is equal to 6.
Or another way we could think
about it is divide the
numerator by 2.
Well, that would give you 6.
And divide the denominator
by 2.
That'll give you 1.
6/1, which is the
same thing as 6.
Now, the other thing we could've
done at this stage
right here is say, well, look,
we have things in the
numerator divisible by 2, we
have things in the denominator
divisible by 2, so let's
divide both by 2.
So 4 divided by 2 is 2.
2 divided by 2 is 1.
So it becomes 2 times 3, which
is 6, over 1 times 1 over 1,
or this is equal to 6.
Now, this could be a fun one
to visualize so let's think
about what this is.
4 divided by 2/3.
Let's draw four boxes here.
Let me do this.
So let's say I have one,
two-- let me separate
them a little bit.
One, two, three, and four.
And you can view 4 divided by
2/3 as let's divide these four
boxes into groups of 2/3 of a
box and figure out how many
groups do we have.
So where are our groups?
So let's see the first group is
going to have 2/3 of a box
in it, so the first group is
going to look like this.
It's going to have
2/3 of a box.
Now, the next group is going to
have 2/3 of a box, so it'll
have 1/3 from here and
then it'll have 1/3
from the next box.
The next group is going to
have 2/3 of the box.
There's 2/3 left right
over here.
Then the group after that will
have another 2/3 of a box.
That is that right over there.
Then the next will have 1/3 from
here and 1/3 from here,
so it'll have 1/3 from here
and 1/3 from here.
That'll be 2/3.
And then the last group will
have 2/3, the leftover on this
box right here.
Now, how many groups
of 2/3 do we have?
We have one, two, three, four,
five, six, so we have six.
Four can be divided into
six groups of 2/3.
So it's just like regular
division, sometimes a little
harder to visualize because
we're dealing with fractions.